Je vais vous emmener à la découverte du lieu où j'ai grandi,
au nord-ouest du Pakistan, un endroit appelé « Dir ».
Dir a été fondé au XVIIe siècle.
C'était un État princier jusqu'à son annexion au Pakistan en 1969.
Notre prince, Nawab Shan Jahan,
se réservait le droit de s'habiller en blanc,
la couleur de l'honneur, pour lui seul.
Il ne croyait pas à l'instruction de son peuple.
Et, lorsque je suis née, en 1979,
seuls 5 % des garçons et 1 % des filles
recevaient un enseignement quel qu'il soit.
J'étais parmi ce 1 %.
En grandissant, je suis restée très proche de mon père.
Il est pharmacien, et il m'a envoyé à l'école.
Chaque jour, j'allais à sa clinique après mes cours.
C'est un homme extraordinaire
et un dirigeant communautaire très respecté.
Il dirigeait une organisation d'aide sociale,
et je l'accompagnais aux réunions sociales et politiques
pour écouter et discuter avec les hommes de la région,
de nos problèmes économiques et sociaux.
Mais, à l'âge de 16 ans,
mon père m'a demandé de ne plus l'accompagner aux réunions publiques.
Maintenant, j'étais une jeune femme, et ma place était à la maison.
J'étais vraiment très contrariée,
mais la plupart des membres de ma famille étaient satisfaits de cette décision.
C'était très difficile pour moi
de rester assise à la maison et de ne plus participer.
Il a fallu deux ans pour que ma famille accepte finalement
que mon père me permette de reprendre contact avec les femmes et les filles,
afin qu'elles puissent discuter de leurs problèmes
et qu'ensemble, nous trouvions des solutions.
Donc, avec sa bénédiction,
j'ai commencé à renouer avec les femmes et les filles
pour resoudre ensemble leurs problèmes.
Quand les femmes participent,
elles apportent avec elles leurs réalités et leurs points de vue.
Pourtant, j'ai constaté bien trop souvent
que les femmes sous-estiment leur force,
leur potentiel, ainsi que leur amour-propre.
Cependant, en renouant avec ces femmes et ces filles,
il m'est apparu très clairement
que s'il y avait une seule chance d'améliorer la vie
de ces femmes et ces filles et leurs familles,
alors, nous devrions lutter pour nos droits
et ne pas attendre que quelqu'un d'autre vienne nous aider.
Donc, par un immense acte de foi,
j'ai fondé ma propre organisation en 1994
afin de créer notre propre plateforme d'émancipation des femmes.
J'ai recruté beaucoup de femmes et de filles pour travailler avec moi.
Ça a été difficile.
Beaucoup de femmes qui travaillaient avec moi ont dû arrêter après leur mariage
parce que leur mari ne voulait pas qu'elles travaillent.
Une de mes collègues a été offerte en cadeau par sa famille
pour racheter un crime que son frère avait commis.
Je n'ai pas pu l'aider,
et je me suis sentie si impuissante à cette occasion.
Mais cela m'a rendu encore plus déterminée à continuer mon combat.
Des pratiques comme celle-ci, j'en ai vu beaucoup,
où ces femmes enduraient cette brutalité en silence.
Mais, quand je vois une femme lutter pour changer sa situation
au lieu d'abandonner, cela me donne de la force.
Donc, je me suis présentée
en tant que candidate indépendante
aux élections locales du Lower Dir, en 2001.
Malgré tous les défis et les obstacles rencontrés tout au long de ce processus,
j'ai été élue.
(Applaudissements)
Et j'ai assumé cette charge publique pendant six ans.
Mais malheureusement, nous les femmes, femmes élues,
nous n'étions pas autorisées à siéger au Conseil
en compagnie de tous les membres
afin de participer aux débats.
Nous devions rester dans une pièce séparée réservée aux femmes,
incapables de savoir ce qui se passait dans le Conseil.
Les hommes m'ont dit :
« Vous, les députées,
vous devriez acheter des machines à coudre pour les femmes »,
quand je savais pertinemment que ce dont elles avaient le plus besoin,
c'était un accès à l'eau potable.
Donc, j'ai fait tout ce que je pouvais
pour répondre en priorité aux difficultés réelles de ces femmes.
J'ai installé cinq pompes manuelles
dans les deux puis desséchés dans ma localité.
Cela a permis de les faire fonctionner de nouveau.
En peu de temps, nous sommes parvenues à rendre l'eau accessible
à plus de 5 000 familles.
Nous avons prouvé que tout ce que les hommes peuvent faire,
pouvait aussi être fait par les femmes.
J'ai construit des partenariats avec d'autres femmes élues,
et l'année dernière,
nous, les femmes, avons pu siéger au Conseil avec tous les autres membres...
(Applaudissements)
... et participer à la préparation des textes de lois,
et aux processus de planification et de budgétisation
dans toutes les décisions.
J'ai découvert que l'union fait la force.
Vous aussi, vous le savez.
Si vous n'êtes pas représenté,
cela veut dire que personne ne lutte pour vos droits.
Le Pakistan
est à plus de 12 000 km d'ici.
Mais j’espère que ce que je vais vous raconter
vous va trouver un écho chez vous,
malgré la grande distance en kilomètres et aussi culturelle qui nous sépare.
Quand les femmes participent, elles amènent avec elles
les réalités et les espoirs de la moitié de la population.
En 2007, nous avons vu la montée des Talibans
à Swat, à Dir et dans les régions voisines.
Terrifiant !
Les Talibans tuaient des innocents.
Presque tous les jours,
les gens recueillaient les corps de leurs proches dans les rues.
La plupart des leaders politiques et sociaux
qui luttaient et travaillaient pour le bien de leurs communautés
ont été menacés et pris pour cible.
Même moi, j'ai du partir
en laissant mes enfants chez mes beaux-parents.
J'ai fermé mon bureau à Dir et j'ai déménagé à Peshawar,
la capitale de ma province.
J'étais en état de choc
tout en continuant à réfléchir à ce que j'allais faire ensuite.
Et la plupart des membres de ma famille et mes amis me suggéraient :
« Shad, arrête de travailler. La menace est trop grave. »
Mais, j'ai préféré continuer.
En 2009,
nous avons connu un afflux historique de personnes déplacées,
venant de Swat, de Dir et des autres régions voisines.
J'ai commencé à visiter les camps, presque tous les jours,
jusqu'à ce que les personnes déplacées
commencent à retourner dans leur région d'origine.
J'ai mis en place quatre unités de santé maternelle et infantile
destinées tout spécialement aux soins de plus de 10 000 femmes et enfants,
non loin des camps.
Mais, vous savez, lors de mes visites,
j'ai constaté que très peu d'attention était accordée aux besoins des femmes.
Et j'ai cherché à en comprendre la raison.
Et j'ai découvert que c'était dû à la sous-représentation des femmes
à la fois sur les plateformes sociales et politiques,
mais aussi dans la société dans son ensemble.
C'est à ce moment-là que j'ai compris
que je devais me concentrer plus particulièrement
sur l'établissement et le renforcement du leadership politique des femmes,
afin d'augmenter leur représentation politique
qui leur permette de faire entendre leurs voix à l'avenir.
Donc; nous avons commencé à former environ 300 candidates potentielles
pour les élections suivantes de 2015.
Et vous savez quoi ?
Cinquante pour cent ont gagnés.
(Applaudissements).
Elles siègent maintenant aux Conseils,
participant activement à la législation, la planification et la budgétisation.
La plupart d'entre elles investissent leurs fonds
dans la santé et l'éducation des femmes,
le développement de leurs compétences et leur accès à l'eau potable.
Toutes ces députées, aujourd'hui,
partagent, discutent et règlent leurs problèmes ensemble.
Laissez-moi vous parler de deux femmes avec lesquelles j'ai travaillé.
Voici Saira Shams.
Cette jeune femme de 26 ans
a gagné les élections du Lower Dir en 2015.
Elle à terminé deux projets d'infrastructure pour la communauté.
Femmes, vous savez, les programmes d'infrastructures communautaires,
certaines personnes pensent que c'est le travail des hommes.
Mais non, c'est aussi le travail des femmes, nous pouvons le faire.
Elle a aussi réparé deux des routes menant aux écoles de filles,
sachant que, sans accès à ces écoles,
ces écoles n'ont aucune utilité pour les filles de DIr.
L'autre jeune femme est Asma Gul.
C'est un membre actif du forum des jeunes leaders que nous avons établi.
Elle ne pouvait pas se porter candidate à une charge publique,
donc elle est devenu la première journaliste femme de notre région.
Elle parle, écrit pour le droit des femmes et des filles, et leurs problèmes.
Saira et Asma sont des exemples vivants
de l'importance de la participation et de la représentation des femmes.
Permettez-moi de vous dire aussi ceci.
En 2013, lors des élections générales au Pakistan,
et en 2015, lors des élections locales,
moins de cent femmes avaient le droit de voter, à Dir.
Mais vous savez quoi?
Je suis fière de vous dire
que cette année, pour les élections générales,
il y avait 93 000 électrices à Dir.
(Applaudissements).
Notre bataille est loin d'être terminée,
mais ce changement est historique.
C'est un signe que les femmes se défendent et participent,
et montrent très clairement que nous devons tous investir
dans l'établissement d"un leadership féminin.
Au Pakistan, tout comme ici, aux États-Unis, et partout dans le monde,
cela veut dire des femmes
en politique, dans le commerce, et en position de pouvoir,
qui prennent des décisions importantes.
Il m'a fallu 23 ans pour venir ici.
Mais je ne souhaite à aucune femme et ni aucune fille
qu'elle ait besoin de 23 années de sa vie pour se faire entendre.
J'ai vécu des périodes sombres,
mais j'ai dépensé chaque instant de ma vie
à travailler pour le droit de chaque femme de s'épanouir pleinement.
Imaginez avec moi,
un monde où des millions d'entre nous prennent la parole
et soutiennent d'autres jeunes filles, ensemble,
en créant des opportunités et des choix
qui profitent à tous.
Et ça, mes amis, ça peut changer le monde.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)